this is the Joo unraveling podcast
episode 39 with Daryl Cooper and myself
Joo willink the date today is October 15
2023 most of the podcasts that I do are
and that you do as well are what are
termed Evergreen podcasts meaning that
you can listen to them at any time and
they still are relevant and make sense
the reason I'm giving the date is
because I think in this situation with
what's going on over in the Holy
Land things are changing very rapidly so
things that we say today may be proven
or disproven or irrelevant or more
relevant in 3 days or 5 days or one hour
depending on the way things unfold so I
just wanted to give that date um Sunday
October 15th 2023 is when we're
recording
this the war in the Holy
Land uh strategic goals of Hamas like
what so they launch this attack they
slaughter people they rape people they
murder people civilians the whole nine
yards when you think about their
strategic goal I I know on the last
podcast we did I I was kind of calling
it a win-win for Hamas in a
way uh you know them they don't do well
if there's peace right that's not
hamas's
platform um as peace was breaking out in
the Middle East between the Abraham
Accords you know with the UAE and
Bahrain and this emerging one that it
looked like was going to happen with
Saudi
Arabia seems to me like their strategic
goal is just to cause chaos in Mayhem
and it seems like it's working
out yeah I think we can glean a little
bit about their strategy from what
happened back in 1996 when the Oslo
Accords were were being negotiated
and you know on both there was a
constituency for peace and making a
settlement on both sides I think on both
sides that constituency was by far the
numerically Superior uh as they were
going on there was a absolutely huge
amount of political capital in Israel in
the United States you know that that
went in and and in the Palestinians I
mean yaser Arafat having to swallow like
a lot of his own pride and and and take
the wrath of his own people like really
uh to to a large degree including Hamas
you know later on like not long after
this there was a civil war between Hamas
and the Palestinian Authority and so a
ton of work had gone into it and Hamas
didn't want it hardcore right-wing
Israelis didn't want it both of them
have maximalist goals that they don't
want to compromise on and they're
willing to do whatever they have to do
to make sure nobody compromises on it
and so a Jewish extreme assassinated the
Israeli Prime Minister Yak Rabin uh for
trying to negotiate peace Hamas blew up
a couple city buses in Tel Aviv uh at
the same intersection in fact in like
success successive weeks and that's all
it took really you know Netanyahu came
to power he was against the peace
process all along and the faction that
said hey this is never going to work we
can't live with these people they they
bomb buses like in the middle of our
cities and you want to make peace with
them those people uh you know maybe
maybe another year would have passed and
they wouldn't have won that election but
they won the election in the aftermath
those attacks and that's always going to
be a presence
that anybody who is looking to moderate
and find a peaceful solution solution to
the situation is going to have to
contend with and I don't know how you
contend with it it's very hard you
know yeah that's when you you hear the
same thing in America right you got the
the far left and the far right
and that's where the problems come from
and it's the same situation you've got
going on
here what about for Israel like what
would you say prior to this happening it
seemed like their strategic goal was to
establish as much stability
throughout through throughout the Middle
East I mean life is going to be easier
for them they're prosperous they don't
want to be fighting a war it seems like
that's that was their strategic goal
before this happened yeah no question
and actually Netanyahu has taken
criticism within is Israel from
politicians and and in the
media because of a real lack of focus on
Gaza and Hamas he had sort of put it
aside as not an immediate concern not
something that you know he came to
office really like to focus on the West
Bank that's what his constituency wanted
him to do they wanted to expand the
settlements increase the number of
settlements in the West Bank and
continue to focus on that and that's
where Israeli security attention has
been over since Netanyahu took over
about a year ago and um you know Israel
I mean I think both sides have short and
long-term goals right and sometimes
those short and long-term goals come
into conflict with one another and it
definitely you see that on the Israeli
side where short term you have
first of all just netanyahu's
government's uh domestic political uh
situation you know this happened on
their watch they could be you know he's
been in office for about a year now so
if you want to hold him responsible for
that it's you know certainly something
that his political enemies are going to
do he needs to make people forget about
that uh especially given he's been
accused in the Israeli media and and in
the parliament of kind of of not NE not
not directly but indirectly partnering
with Hamas because they share his
hostility to a two-state
solution um and so how do you do that
how do you you know he Netanyahu has to
go in he has to go in hard he has to do
enough damage to
Hamas that they can feel like they have
some breathing room that another
attack's not going to happen next week
if they leave and and also to to
let the Israeli people know that if if
they want to kill us then people are
going to pay for it did you notice a
little change I noticed a little change
at least I think I noticed a change
initial reaction from Israeli government
was we are going to completely destroy
Hamas we're g to I believe I heard like
we're going to kill everyone yeah every
M of every member of Hamas is a dead man
I don't know if you've noticed recently
it's changed to we're going to eliminate
any military capability that they have
so that's a shift did you have you
noticed that or is that just me hearing
what I want to hear no I think that is a
shift uh and it's a much it's a shift
toward a much more realistic goal right
um because you know getting rid of
Hamas it's kind of similar to when
people talk about how we should go down
and get rid of the cartels it's like
well who's a cartel member the bosses
yeah you know his M main Cadre of
Shooters and distributors fine but
really like this is kind of a
distributed network of people who you
know sometimes you do a job for the Cel
you Curry or something here and there
but really you're just some dude's
nephew and nobody would necessarily
consider you a cartel member so what are
you GNA do you're going to go kill all
those people you know then you're going
to create a bigger problem for yourself
because Israel's
long-term strategic
consideration I think Israel's Israel's
number number one sort of long-term
worry right is that the longer the the
occupation goes on the longer they have
this stateless Refugee population on
their border over whom they exercise
military
control uh and therefore are going to be
held responsible for by the rest of the
world the longer that goes on the more
they run the risk of becoming the next
South Africa in terms of like they being
a global movement to put pressure on
them to change the
like on terms that they would not that
would not be acceptable to them right
now eventually the South Africans had no
choice there was just so much Global
pressure from the west and the East
during the Cold War that they that they
had no choice but to change and Israel
runs the risk I mean you see in London
50,000 people gathering in London waving
Palestinian Flags you see the same thing
in European capitals not in France they
banned all the pro Palestine marches in
France but and even in the United States
you see it there's a lot more
equivocation a lot more yeah
but than than we're used to seeing after
Arab attacks against Israel in the past
well that's one of the one of the
biggest points that I wanted to talk
about today was information operations
and in my assessment right now even from
what you just said adds to
this uh the winner the people that are
winning the information operations is
Hamas and the people that are losing
information operations is
Israel when you see like and for people
that don't know what information
operations it's it's probably I don't
know I don't have the military
definition on hands but it's like the
all-encompassing H how are we telling
the story you know how are we getting
our story out there how are we
propagating what's happening and
propagandizing what's happening and how
are we making people understand the
predicament that we're in and how we're
handling it and right now in my
assessment Israel is not winning that
information operation and one of the
things which is amazing when you think
about it after what just happened yep
you know the extreme nature of of this
attack by Hamas that already Israel is
struggling to maintain control of the
narrative do you agree with me I do yeah
especially outside the United States you
know the United States is always more
more pro- Israel than the Europeans let
alone the rest of the world but even
here um compared to previous previous
Wars and conflicts and attacks it's turn
it's turning faster than it has in the
past it's kind of crazy to think that
it's kind of crazy to think that that
Hamas is winning the
information operations the information
campaign it's crazy to think that they
just went and attacked Israel and
murdered and killed and raped and in a
week people are you know like you said
yah butting that and and and Hamas is
winning the information that's a shock
yeah well let me ask you this real quick
for while it's in my head would the
United States have been better off if in
the immediate aftermath of September
11th uh where you know I don't care if n
Chomsky was President we were kicking
somebody's ass period and but would we
have been better off the United States
have been better off if in the immediate
aftermath of that people would have said
you know not yeah but Al-Qaeda is
Justified in doing this or anything like
that but what is uh the United States
doing over in some of these countries
like what did what did the Osama Bin
Laden actually say he's angry about yeah
why are we doing that having those
conversations and they're hard to have
when 3,000 or 1,000 people are you
know are are dead
but you know I the problem is with
Israel is a lot of the people who want
to force that narrative and those
questions on them uh
a lot of those people are just outright
hostile to Israel they're not looking
for self-reflection or moderation
they're hostile and so that's a
different it is different in that sense
well obviously anytime something happens
you've got to look and at yourself and
see what did I do to cause this to
happen and it's you know like the the
people from Harvard or the students
groups from Harvard that said Israel is
solely responsible for what has just
happened happened
right again you talk about some people
that have some hostilities towards
Israel and that's not a that's not a
self-reflective comment to say that
that's just like senseless but let me
let me steal man it a little bit and I
don't agree with that statement like the
the their the Harvard student statement
but and by the way it wasn't the Harvard
students certain 31 of the people I
don't want to group everyone Harvard
together but yeah go ahead um you know
and I I tweeted this out and my
typically Prov itive way uh in the last
several days and got a mixed response
you know some people don't don't like a
question like this other people were
more thoughtful about it uh which is you
know it's a reasonable question to ask
whether a stateless Refugee
population confined to an area ringed by
a wall that is patrolled by remote
controlled machine gun robots which Gaz
is whether the people in there can ever
actually really inroad sense be the
aggressors against the state that put
them there and keeps them there like
that's not an unreasonable question in
my opinion now you know that doesn't
really it wouldn't affect my
decision-making process if I was the
Israeli Prime Minister you know you have
an obligation to protect and and
retaliate if you can't protect your
people um but if you look back at like
the United States during the frontier
days you know there were Indian attacks
Indian raids they killed whole families
they mutilated corpses all these
terrible things and
those things were were used to justify
continue expansion and retaliation by
the United States but like if today the
American Indian movement started bombing
you know shopping malls and stuff
everybody would look at that very
differently than they look at Crazy
Horse or somebody attacking back in the
1800s that that's them resisting the
loss I we see what became of the Native
Americans they're resisting that nobody
would really begrudge them you know
their their right to resist that
Palestinians it's such a unique case
because you know this is something that
has been going on for really about 100
110 years now Israel's been around since
48 and normally
when you know you have a successful
colonization project like Israel did and
you push a lot of the people who lived
in that territory out to the periphery
outside the borders of your
State uh that's sort of the end of the
matter maybe a generation or two goes by
and the people who lost their homes or
whatever are are not around anymore and
it's it becomes a histo question for
historical debate rather than a policy
debate and the Palestinians have never
stopped fighting never stopped resisting
partly because uh of the Arab states and
the support and encouragement that
they've given them and so this is
something that is really a relic of an
earlier historical period that has
persisted into the present day you know
yeah and I think that's I think that
whole that whole thing that you just
laid out is one of the primary reasons
why I think
Hamas is winning the information
operations because they're going out to
an audience a global
audience that
is more open and receptive to
this to to to to what the story that
they're saying and that's what they want
to hear that's what they want to believe
and it becomes it becomes really
problematic one of one of the one of the
things that I noticed you know I woke up
in the morning and a few days ago and
the lead story was Israel had killed one
of the one of the leaders of Hamas that
was the lead story
and you know as I went through social
media and and and through like that you
had the couple briefings from Israel
that was like we conducted this
operation we killed this person
um that's just continuing the same
narrative that that that message doesn't
help
Israel what Israel in my opinion should
be doing is yes this morning we
conducted the following humanitarian
operations this morning we escorted
these people to safety this morning we
provided medical care for the following
pal Palestinian people that had come to
this checkpoint that we had set up for
anyone that was under medical need today
we conducted a humanitarian operation to
that's what they should be that's what
they should be doing they're not doing
that all they're reporting on you know
we killed this guy we we're getting
ready to assault this area we dropped
this many bombs we destroyed this it's
it's all about War and what are the what
are the Palestinians replying with or
what sorry what is Hamas what is the
social media and what is the news coming
out of Hamas all of they're not saying
they're done saying we attacked now
they're just saying this child was
killed this woman was killed this family
was killed here's the child buried in
rubble so there's the stories there's
the stories that the two elements are
are putting out into the world and you
can see how the world is taking it you I
was actually thinking let's say boom um
you know everyone that's protesting in
support of
of the Palestinians right now and again
do I say supporting Hamas or do I say
supporting the
Palestinians it's one of those things
that's difficult right because if it's
September 12th 2001 and your response is
to go out into the streets and protest
you know against us involvement in the
Middle East and all that kind of stuff
maybe you're not technically going out
and protesting in favor of al-Qaeda but
on September 12 2001 that's different
than if you were to do it today you know
and so this is an immediate aftermath
it's but these folks that are going out
and protesting and that's what they're
seeing in their social media feed
they're saying Yep this is right you
know we're on the right side because
these people are the underdog these
people are the oppressed and therefore
we should support them what's
interesting is let's say let's say Iran
joins the war let's say Hezbollah goes
on a full-on assault that's supported
and let's say they get the upper hand
and let's say the tables turn and now
all of a sudden it's it's Israeli that's
on the losing end of combat and you
start to
see and Israeli starts to put out oh yep
here's our which they did for a day
right they did for a day there was these
mass killings and they and and the weird
thing was they went straight to like
burned babies right like hey this is
what we're up against and it was almost
like that was a setup like okay here's
burn babies stand by yeah right yeah as
opposed to this is what we're living
like and this is what we've been through
it was it was like this is what we're
living like this is what we've been
through so stand by it was like
immediately they went right there so if
you turn the tables and Israel
started being on the losing end
militarily and their civilians were
getting killed on a regular basis would
what would what would that messaging
look like and would people start to say
oh this has got to stop I can't believe
this is happening I can't believe all
these Arab countries are ganging up on
poor little Israel would people flip
then to support
the people who the underdog who who
would become the underdog the people who
are currently protesting in favor of the
Palestinians probably not you know I I I
don't think that they probably would
because I think there's mixed
motivations there's people who are just
genuinely sympathetic toward the
Palestinian cause there's people who
just don't like Israel they don't like
there's people who don't like Jews on
the other side there's people who don't
like Muslims don't like Arabs you know
and like so there's a there there's a
real mix of motivations that that
probably would lock people in but I mean
I think if if Israel if the tide turned
against Israel militarily especially if
Iran was involved we would U we'd be at
war in the Middle East probably for sure
and right now there's Iran is making
they're they're they're giving warnings
I mean again this is October 15th
there's been news this morning I've been
whatever I've been out of the loop for
like 6 hours right now cuz I've been
recording and doing other stuff but 6
hours is a long time but that's what as
was coming in this morning there was
threats being made by Iran right now
that hey if this continues we're going
to we're going to do something am I
right yeah I mean I wonder what it is
they think they can do they can launch
missiles at uh at Israel I suppose but
they got to know that's going to invite
massive retaliation from the United
States I mean we would definitely attack
them and then that would get really ugly
right I mean you think of all of the US
military installations the Baghdad
Embassy and so forth that are in Easy
reach of what I have to imagine is a
massive stockpile of of of rockets and
missiles on the Iranian part I mean it's
it it would be ugly I mean there's a you
know Iran is a tough nut to crack
because all the places we normally stage
like where that we use say before the
Iraq War Kuwait you know just all those
places are within easy reach of Iranian
missiles you can't really come in from
the East and drive across a, or 1500
miles of desert Plateau before you hit a
major city and so you kind of have to go
through Iraq I guess because turkey
probably is not going to allow us to do
anything from there and so you know a
lot of the people who are like just kick
Iran's ass it's like look we could
launch a bunch of tomahawk missiles and
stuff but I think we've seen you know
people people have an idea of like you
launch a bunch of missiles and it does
like World War II scale damage to you
know military and civilian
infrastructure but it doesn't I we don't
have that many of these things and so if
you and a real fight with Iran is a is a
very tough tough thing to plan and and
to predict like which way it would
go uh you know when I was talking just
to catch up one thing uh when I was
talking about humanitarian operations
and like in my opinion if Israel had if
Israel wants to project a better
story they should a conduct these
humanitarian operations B talk about
them and some people would say like well
there's a huge risk to those things and
there absolutely is there is a risk when
you start to do humanitarian operations
and you know the example to talk about
is like in Iraq the amount of effort
that American forces went through to
prevent collateral damage and to conduct
humanitarian operations was crazy like
you're going out to uh you know help
someone build a a a a irrigation
pipeline in a city you're out there all
day like you're out there you have
security but you're going to get
attacked and you might lose two soldiers
like think about that you lose two
soldiers that were out there helping put
in an irrigation pipe that's freaking
sickening and you might say well it's
not worth it
well there there's that risk is always
going to be there when you conduct these
type of
operations but if you don't if you
ignore those things then you just end up
looking like the bad guy yeah and so
there's some I don't want to say that
these like type of humanitarian
operations are without risk they
certainly would be and I'm sure there's
you know a bunch of Hardline Israelis
hearing me say that thinking you're an
idiot we would never do that these are
people that just attacked us this is why
when we make decisions we have to really
look at things from a strategic picture
and what we want a final outcome to be
because look if you're Israel and you're
like well I'm a hard ler and we're just
going to uh destroy everyone well first
of all that's not realistic and second
of all where does that where does that
put you put you on the defensive for the
next next 500 years you're watching your
back for the next 500 years there's no
prosperity in the region like it's just
a nightmare for you if you try and move
things in a more positive direction
which sucks when the extreme
organization that you're fighting
against just murdered a bunch of your
civilians I know it sucks I know it
sucks it's freaking awful it's
terrible yet if you look at things if
you detach from your emotions and look
I'm not saying you throw your emotions
away but if you detach from them so
you're not making emotional decisions
you put it in the calculus but it should
be with other factors you shouldn't make
decisions purely based on emotion it
should be emotion should be in there but
you've also got to think long term
you've got to think strategically where
we're going to be we got to think about
the resources that we have we got to
think about all these different
components that allow us to make a
decision that's going to be a good
decision not just today not just
tomorrow not just for our emotional
situation but for where we're going to
be and where we want to
be so because basically what you're
saying is you're you're pointing to to
something that people often say which is
you can do whatever you want to Gaza as
long as the conditions that exist there
continue to exist
then there's going there's going to be
more attacks like that that is just a it
is a breeding ground for violence it
doesn't matter what else you do like you
have to actually address that problem
and it's kind of similar to like you
know the argument of of of people who
want to control immigration the United
States or shut down immigration to the
United States there's always you you
want to do something about it and so
what do you want to do you want to build
a wall build a big like Game of Thrones
wall and keep them out when like
really what's the only way that you
could really fix illegal immigration to
the United States it's if Mexico and El
Salvador and Nicaragua and all those
countries Venezuela were actually safe
and prosperous then that would fix the
problem but that's you know that's not
it's not an easy sell especially I mean
you know at a time like this you know
I'm somebody who can
admit that if I was born in Gaza as an
Arab if I was born in
Israel given my natural inclinations and
and the conditions in which I would have
been would have been raised I would be
an extremist partisan for my side and I
can understand that now it has I try to
make that have the paradoxical effect of
making me less extreme My Views toward
either side because I do kind of
understand that I would I would be on
either side of this fight depending on
on where I was coming
from um well that's a good point and as
I've been thinking about so in Gaza and
I saw a bunch of pictures of the child
child soldiers they probably look like
they're between 10 and 12 years old and
they're all geared up in Gaza ready to
fight um and you know half a little over
half the population of Gaza is under 16
years old right which means they're the
product of they've been born and raised
in that environment so they are going to
be you know I you know I texted you a
little bit about this but there is some
level of comparison with North Korea of
like people in North Korea that's what
they think the world is they think that
the entire West is against them they
think that they might go to war with
America tomorrow they think like they
don't have access so Gaza has some of
that going on
undoubtedly you know and just like in
North Korea they're living in terrible
conditions well we're living in terrible
conditions in Gaza the the people that
are doing this over across that wall
they're living in good conditions why
are we stuck here like this so there
there is some level
of comparison between North Korea and
Gaza that being said when you have these
these child
soldiers
um just
like you you would look at North Korea
and say well I understand why these
North Korean soldiers are behaving the
way they do well I understand why these
child soldiers in Gaza are looking to
behave the way they're about to be
behave um and and it's another
indication that Hamas doesn't really
care I mean
Hamas has got these kids jocked up yeah
they don't care about death the way we
think of yeah at all yeah and I'll go
one step further every every Palestinian
that gets killed in Gaza is a
celebration for Hamas it's a it's a it's
a opportunity for them it's a tactical
victory yeah for sure it's a tactical
victory for them and the younger they
are and the more innocent they are the
better it is for Hamas yeah I was
talking to somebody the other day who we
both know uh who was telling me and he's
usually pretty critical of Israel but he
was talking about how his mother-in-law
had a good friend lives over in Israel
and she was down in southern Israel and
she got kidnapped and murdered executed
by Hamas during this
attack and he was going to interview
another guy who takes sort of the pro
Palestinian uh perspective and he was
going to interview him and he thought
that he should tell him that before the
interview just to kind of be upfront if
he has any emotional bias or anything
like that here's what's going on with
that and so he told him that so hold on
set this up for me one more time the
person that's interviewing yeah the
Palestinian yeah uh Pro Palestine guy I
Palestinian yeah um that his
mother-in-law had a friend who was
murdered by Hamas and he told the guy
the pro Palestine guy he was
interviewing that piece of information
just so he kind of knows where he's
coming from like through the course of
the conversation and the other guy says
that's terrible and then he tells him
that his entire family had been killed
the day before his both of his
grandparents cousins both of his parents
and all but one of his siblings all
killed by an Israeli air strike and the
dude was like the guy doing the
interview was like oh my gosh and so
they just didn't even bring it up during
their interview but you know that's like
that's kind of the thing like you know
if you have a a conflict that has been
going on for basically a
century
with countless I mean just laundry list
of mass atrocities committed by both
sides over the years
and nobody can seem to resolve it
despite massive uh incentives to do that
for the people involved for foreign
countries that want a feather in their
cap for brokering a piece whatever
despite all that you have something
going on for a hundred years like that
the idea that one side or the other is
just solely to blame is that's sort of a
child's way of thinking you know it's
not it's just not an adult way of
looking at it for example like there was
uh one usually the second biggest
Palestinian resistance organization over
the years ever since' 67 when it was
founded is a secular socialist group
called The pflp pal popular front for
the liberation of
Palestine and it was founded by a
Palestinian Christian named George
habash in 1967 and over the years
they've carried out some of the most
barbaric attacks that everybody
remembers from you from from the history
of this conflict uh including uh
sponsoring those Japanese terrorists who
shot up the benguan airport in what was
it 72 or
something and that guy George habash was
18 or 19 years old living in the town of
L with his family in 1948 when the
Israeli Army came in and drove them all
out into the desert at gunpoint and took
over that town and just a lot of people
died walking out in the desert people
call it a Death March and you know maybe
that's it's not like thousands of people
died you know it was like probably
dozens maybe maybe over a hundred but
still terrible they were definitely like
you know at least on the scale of that
town you would say ethnically cleansed
from that town you know an army comes in
says everybody get out and then they
take it over you're not allowed to come
back um he was there and so that guy had
this happen to him and his family 1967
he starts a terrorist organization the
pflp that organization carries out
gruesome murders and massacres of
Israelis over the years and those dead
Israelis those people have sons and
brothers and sister you know and other
relatives too and
so this is you know there's this the
cycle of
violence began at a time and I kind of
touched on this earlier but it it began
at a time when the world was very
different than it is now you know
1948 that's right after like 1948 is
when the Zionist forces drove 700 to
800,000 Palestinians out of their towns
and Villages pushed them out into these
refugee camps where they've been sitting
ever since massive atrocity like you
know if that were to happen today we
would look at that as as something
that's totally unacceptable this was
three years after the second world war
you had the Germans and Japanese just
Mass violence against civilian
populations we were flattening Japanese
and German cities like it was just going
out of style we had had the the Soviet
Union was legitimized by the Allies to
the point that they were that these
Soviet butchers literally people
individual people individual Soviets who
had tens of thousands had their
signature on tens of thousands of
murders like literally signed the papers
sat in Judgment of war crimes at nurg
and so you know and in 1948 they were
still in the process of just Mass
violence on an extreme level in Eastern
Europe as they conquered and
Consolidated their control over Eastern
Europe that's what's going on in the
world you know 1950s we killed something
like 20% of the entire population of
North Korea a lot of it with heavy
bombers against a an enemy that didn't
really have an Air Force of its own so I
mean this is the world at the time this
is how the world operates and so uh in
that context I mean shoot four or five
million Germans in Czechoslovakia and
Poland and other places all got
ethnically cleansed and sent pack and
back to Germany and so when that's the
context in which the cycle of violence
starts you know it's just normally uh
this is the reason this is the way it is
is that it's the longest running one
it's like this it's this call back to
this earlier kind of barbaric primitive
age when we were all every country you
know even the good countries were just
massacring each other's civilians in
war and this one has just carried on
that cycle of violent because you know
because after the second world war with
the creation of the United Nations with
the Cold War considerations the
propaganda considerations of the Cold
War uh it became impossible for anybody
Israel in this case to actually complete
the job if the Israelis had moved into
Palestine in 1890 instead of you know
say 1888 instead of 1948 and done the
same exact thing that they had done in
1948 and 184 in 1888 this none of this
would be an issue anymore this would be
something that uh that they did at a
time when that was totally normal to do
but they did this sort of you know again
the UN existed it was post World War II
is we had to worry about the Soviets
saying you know that the US are is
supporting this colonization project you
know in the Middle East and so it's
prevented the Israelis from ever
actually going in and doing anything
that would that would finish the job
which I'm not endorsing that that's a
horrific thing like just all these
things I'm talking about in the past
were were horrible but they resolved the
issue Japan stopp being a problem
Germany stopped being a problem and we
were able to move on and and and that's
coming from somebody who's very critical
of of a lot of the stuff that even the
Allies did in in the Second World War uh
strategic bombing campaigns and
everything else um very critical of that
stuff but in the aftermath of that war
we were able to be friends with Germany
again we were able to move on and Israel
has never been able to do that because
this whole conflict it started in the
old world but it's taken place almost
entirely in the new world where none of
those things are really allowed to
happen
anymore what is it then
that is it is it the fact that the
Palestinians that got you know uh
removed from
Israel they didn't have anywhere to go
is it like what what why would you say
that this is different other than the
time frame that it lasted because you
know I I've always said well I used to
say this about you know um Germany and
Japan like we needed to stay there for a
couple generations and then a couple
Generations goes by and now you're like
okay then people have now seen that this
is the way it's going to be now and and
and you kind of move past it I've I said
that about Iraq I said it's going to
take a couple Generations we didn't say
there but if you really want you know
the the dream of this having this sort
of democratic type uh country over there
with peace and prosperity Prosperity it
was I used to say hey it's going to take
a couple Generations it's going to take
a couple Generations when people say oh
I understand the way that this western
style of living works because they don't
understand it at first it's totally
different you know the classic example I
use is you know the the officers would
take money from their soldiers they'd
skim their paychecks we all think that's
crazy we we would talk to him about it
and be like well of course of course my
boss is going to take some of our money
that's the way that's the way the world
works so to get rid of that corruption
would take a couple Generations because
the people that grew up that way and
probably their kids aren't going to
process a totally new way of living yeah
and so where you know how how has this
how has this um history sustained itself
from generation to generation to
generation to generation what four four
or five generations so a huge part of it
is that Palestine has always been used
by uh the Arab country or now the just
say the Muslim countries in the Middle
East
as as a as a means for for Arab leaders
to and now the Ayatollah to to
bolster their own reputation throughout
the region is I'm the one who's going to
stand up to the zionists finally after
they humiliated Us in 1948 they
humiliated Us in 1967 The Whole World's
on their side I'm G to stand up to them
this is why NASA was so popular it's
it's why you know you would think okay
Iran this is a Persian
country you got Iraq and Syria between
Israel and it it's way over there why is
Israel like such a focus for them and
part of it is you know fine I'm sure
there's like a certain level of Muslim
solidarity or whatever but there's calc
there's political calculations going on
here and they understand that it is one
of those issues that they can rally
people around and that they can use to
delegitimize their rivals in the region
like their other Arab and Muslim rivals
in the region for not being sufficiently
uh strong on the issue and that is
always happening so you know people
bring up even still today they say well
why
didn't Egypt just absorb the people of
Gaza they're just Arabs they're you know
Palestinians okay fine but that's like a
hundred years old really that like that
was a national identity anybody took
seriously why didn't the ones in Gaza
just go become Egyptians the ones in the
West Bank in Jordan just go become
jordanians and syrians and Lebanese and
so forth
and if this had all happened in 1888
that's exactly what would have happened
um but you know you run into this
problem where once the ethnogenesis
takes place once you have this group of
people who are self it's kind of like
you know what it's very similar to like
the arguments Putin tries to put out
about Ukraine like oh this is not like a
hundred years ago these people all
considered themselves Russians this is
all a modern invention this is like a
legacy of the Soviet stuff this is not
real these people are Russian and the
thing is like all of Putin's historical
takes on that might be correct but it
doesn't matter because they're there now
and and once they're there now and that
that ethnogenesis is taken place and
that Collective identity solidified it's
not going anywhere so so it became like
a rallying cry 100% that's that that's
to now that you're you're kind of
talking through that to me that's the
word that comes to mind is that for all
these years it's become a rallying cry
for the Islamic World primarily to say
look we there's there's no easier way to
unify people than to point at Point at a
bad guy or or point at a positive goal
right you've got a bunch of people that
are kind of you know you work at a
company and there's a bunch of people
with a bunch of different things going
on and no one's really focusing you say
you know what we're Ford and we're going
to race against Ferrari right and we're
going to beat him like that's a unifying
thing to do well that's a great way to
unify a bunch of people is hey we uh
lost a couple Wars we lost a bunch of
land we're going to get it back yeah and
bring that up over and over again it's a
nightmare and
you know in in a in a lot of these
countries the Arab street is more
extreme on this issue than their own
leaders and so you know you look at a
place like Jordan you look at a place
like Saudi Arabia even now that Muhammad
bin Solomon's in there Egypt these are
all countries that are perfectly capable
of coexisting with Israel but they are
sitting you know they're ruling over
populations that that have different
views on that question you know
sometimes and I mean so you know one of
the things that's absolutely needed is
leadership in those countries leadership
that can actually lead their populations
down down in that
direction but yeah go ahead well um I
think one of the really kind of just
things where Israel
wins is you know as we pointed out in
the beginning like Israel's goal is
peace and stability and security and to
unify with as or or work alongside as
many people as we can and like let's
move forward and that's why I think uh
you know again when we look at what's
happening right
now okay it seems like what Israel wants
would be a nice
thing and to me that's sort of
like the most positive way to look at it
but it's kind of similar though to like
the the Russians right now have control
of donbass they have control of
Crimea uh they may you know they're in
the process of taking over more and the
Russians would say look we just want
peace stop fighting ukrainians why are
you still fighting we're ready to
negotiate right now and just end this
whole thing oh no we're not giving back
Crimea let not getting carried away
that's ours but and so for the UK you
know and and so from a certain
perspective you could look at it and say
what it's the ukrainians are the ones
responsible for carrying on this
conflict the Russians are ready to kind
of stop things where they are and and
let it sit the ukrainians aren't willing
to accept that so aren't they the ones
responsible for this conflict even
though they were the ones that got
invaded right because there's there's
two there's these two questions that
have obvious
answers and yet those obvious answers
completely contradict one another in
terms of how they get app applied
practically one is do the Israelis have
does the Israeli government have a a
right and responsibility to defend its
own people and to retaliate when they're
attacked of course like that's just an
obious it's almost a nonsecretor of
course they do should the Palestinians
just sort of accept that they lost their
Homeland and that's that and or do they
have a right to
resist and that's kind of got an obvious
answer to in the sense of surely they
have a right you know there's they're
not like
the the moral balance is not completely
tipped against them if they want to
continue to resist uh what has happened
you know a lot of these towns down in in
southern Israel that just got attacked
by Hamas ashalon is is uh the the sort
of most well-known one right there on
the on the southern coast those were you
know up until 1948 those were fully
Palestinian towns and those people all
got driven out and and their grandkids
and great grandkids live in refugee
camps in these places uh administered by
the UN living off of you know Aid uh
from the UN and from other countries
drinking you know their water out of
those little bags and like everything
else and if you're an if you're a young
Arab dude a young
Palestinian and you look around you and
you see your grandmother and your
grandfather and your mother and your
sisters and brothers and they're all
living in this cinder block in tin
Shanty and the town that they were
driven out of in fact the house is still
standing it's right over there it's 5
miles away it's 10 miles away like on
the other side of that that wall around
Gaza that's patrolled by the machine gun
robots uh you can't go get her Town her
house back uh but you can go burn that
house down and that's kind of been the
mentality of the Palestinians for a long
time which is you know and and I mean
you know me like I I try to have like
a what I would call like a a nuanced
view on the situation other people say
it's it's kind of relativist or whatever
and I I accept that it comes across that
way certainly in the aftermath of an
attack like just happened and so you
know if you're if you're like a hardcore
pro-israel person a lot of people read
my tweets and and and see my takes on it
and they think I'm way too Pro Palestine
too sympathetic to them and and that's
fine I get that but I'm the first one to
admit that for a long time now the
Palestinian resistance has really been
like a
nihilistic violent just
very we talk about hamas's long-term
strategic goals it's not that they
exactly have none but I really think
that their secondary
considerations they want to hurt and
kill the people that have continued to
keep them in this humiliating position
that's the way they see it and what's
the long-term plan with that it's like
sometimes you know if you're if you're
living in a place like Gaza where like
what's your best case scenario for your
future is pretty shitty you know as far
as how your life's going to go
uh it's you make you make very
short-term calculations that that
override everything else and it's and
it's been that way for a long time now
it really has I mean I would say at
least since you could argue it's been
like this since since before the 48 War
but definitely like the official
Palestine resistance organizations how
they you know if you go back to like the
50s and 60s you would have Palestinians
like that dude who who can't go get his
grandma's house back but he can burn
that house down those kind of raids
would happen thing there would be
killings and and uh sabotage and Things
by individual little groups of friends
or something but as far as the Palestine
resistance organizations up until up
through the 50s and and really until the
late 60s even for the most part I would
say mid-60s they were focused on
attacking Israeli military checkpoints
ambushing uh soldiers on patrol it was a
military situation and when you got into
the 1970s that all changed and they just
started engaging in the kind of
terrorism that that we've become used to
now just Mass killing of civilians find
the softest possible Target kill as many
people as you can and then die
and when that's what any resistance
movement or or or just any kind of
movement has been reduced
to man it's really hard to to keep any
of their historical claims or grievances
in mind for very long yeah you know well
that's where I think if you look at from
that perspective over that time period
that's when they were losing completely
losing the information operations
because they were doing these things
they had I think the way you described
it as nihilistic that's a great way to
describe it and people look at them from
the outside so like wait a second you
just killed a bunch of women and kids
you blew up a bus you blew up a school
you invaded school like all those things
are they're they're suicidal not just
suicidal for the individuals that
execute but it's like borderline
suicidal for the
movement and they did nothing during
that time frame to gain popular support
ACR globally right and it's only now
again that's why it surprises me to see
Hamas sort of winning the information
operations but you know what if they
would have had a Gandhi leader um a
Martin Luther King leader and they took
that approach during the late
1960s yeah you you don't know right
because Gandhi's tactics would not have
worked on the
Mongols the question of whether you know
because the thing is is like when you
get down to
it and this is the this is just sort of
the unfortunate and and dark reality of
the
situation is that both sides
have have claims that that look uh
justifiable from their own perspective
100% righteous and justifiable that are
just absolutely mutually exclusive you
know like there there is
no there is no settlement that is even
being remotely discussed in before this
attack that's even being remotely
discussed in Israel that is remotely
acceptable to the Palestinians that that
the Palestinians don't see as just
ratifying their own ethnic cleansing and
saying everything that's happened to us
in the years since then that's all water
under the bridge and we're just going to
sort of accept the scraps that we can
get there's no settlement on offer that
doesn't look that way to them there is
no settlement on offer even from the ma
moderate Palestinian uh
people that is remotely acceptable to
even like the Israeli liberals because I
mean you think about like people talk
about a one-state or a two-state
solution right one-state solution is
basically the the idea that you know
like if you go back to the American
Civil War like before and just after it
there were a lot of people in the United
States including abolitionists people
who hated
slavery who wanted the slaves all freed
but they weren't remotely even thinking
about bringing the slaves in as as uh
citizens allowing them to vote and our
democratic system or anything like that
they they didn't but and they they had
all these like outlandish plans or how
to repat them to Africa or settle them
off in in Central America or something
but the the but what ended up happening
like the thing that kind of the argument
that won the day is like yeah look like
yeah these people are probably going to
be angry at you at us for a long time
you enslaved them you kidnap them from
their home all these kind of things and
that is probably it's going to be hard
to integrate them successfully into your
Society to as Citizens like there's
going to be difficulties there no doubt
about it but you broke it you bought it
it like this is these people are your
responsibility whether you like it or
not and there are people who will say
look at uh you know the the is Israel
was formed in
1948 the 1967 war that's 19 years into
Israel's existence that's the period of
time that the Palestinians were not
living under Israeli military occupation
so they've been under Israeli occupation
for three times as long as they weren't
under it and there's people that look at
it and say look you can say these people
aren't Israelis but you've been making
decisions for them and controlling uh
you know their their towns and cities
and their security their physical
security for three times longer than
they ever lived without that and so
these people are yours like whether you
like it or not make them Israeli
citizens and and let them participate
give them civil rights now of course the
problem with that is if you did that uh
overnight the population of Israel the
Jewish population of Israel goes down to
about 45 or
50%
and it's unrealistic to the in the
extreme to expect that uh everybody is
just going to wake up the next day and
sort of be liberal individualists who
don't vote in accordance with their
identity group and so Israel would the
one state solution would force the
choice on Israel do you want to stay a
democracy or do you want to stay a
Jewish State because those two things
would become mutually exclusive which
means that the one state solution is not
going to Happ happen the two-state
solution is a little more
straightforward and simple in the sense
that it's just okay the Palestinians are
all on the West Bank in
Gaza we would have to figure out how to
connect those two places maybe like a
highway Network or something and that's
you know there's some difficulty there
maybe some Geographic concessions in the
in the desert down there in the South uh
but that this let it be another country
Let It Be its own state with a un seat
and all these kind of things and there
have been over the years a lot of like
Israeli right-wingers who have been in
favor of this this because they look at
it as an easier problem to deal with you
know if you have a foreign State over
here with an army and a embassies in in
in capitals around the world and they're
sponsoring terrorist attacks against
your civilians you have a different
range of options available to you than
if this is a sort of refugee population
that doesn't have a state that you're in
control of militarily and they're do it
just gives you a wider range of options
not to mention the fact that people made
this argument when homas took over Gaza
Israelis they were like there were some
people like we can't let Hamas take over
Gaza this is crazy they're terrorists
other people just to clarify this is
what you're talking about when when Gaza
got voted into power in Gaza yeah and
who you know I don't sorry when Hamas
got voted and I don't know really uh the
details of how that vote went down
whether it's you know people were
intimidated or what I I actually don't
know much about that I should probably
look more into it but they but Hamas was
voted in in 2006 that was the last
election that was ever held though and
there were Israelis at at the time who
were like we can't let Hamas become the
government in Gaza it's insane these
people are are uh terrorists they're
murderers but there are other people
even people further to the right of of
the first ones who said well wait a
second here Hamas is a lot easier to
find if they're in you know the
headquarters building over there and
that's their Communications building and
this is their military training that's a
lot easier to deal with we know where to
find them we know how to deal with that
a little bit better than we do this sort
of weird Insurgency situation
where uh and so I mean you go back even
to 1967 David benon who was the leader
of the Zionist movement for decades uh
leading up to that point when the
Israelis took over the West Bank in Gaza
from Egypt in Jordan he was like give it
back give it back are you crazy like we
don't want millions of Palestinians that
now we are going to be responsible for
and whether we like it or not the
world's going to look at us and be like
well look you have military P if you
have military patrols going to through
their towns and
Villages you're responsible for those
people whether you like it or not and
that is what has kind of
happened and you know the two-state
solution there's a problem with that one
too though unfortunately which is that
uh you know there are about 450,000
Israeli s settlers scattered in
communities throughout the West Bank um
over a hundred of those communities are
illegal even according to Israeli law
but there's no political will there's no
political faction in Israel that has the
will or the power uh to repatriate those
people and they're scattered into places
that really break up the contiguity of
any prospective Palestinian State and so
these people would either end up as a
minority in a Palestinian State Jewish
minority in a Palestinian state which is
not something anybody would be prepared
to tolerate at least right now or they
would have to go back and in the past
past couple decades you know when Israel
has tried to just evacuate a few hundred
settlers uh is Israeli settlers from
from places that
were you know that one of the illegal
settlements but one that was causing a
particular problem in in their dealings
with the Palestinian Authority just a
few hundred people they tried to move
out and there were riots across the
settlements they were fighting Israeli
Security Forces it got it got pretty
ugly and so you're going to do that to
450,000 people no you're not it's just
not going to happen and
so I mean the one and two State
Solutions are are they're really just
they they they both would force one side
or the other or both sides to accept
things that there's no way they could
accept you just you you you know that
you just couldn't
and you always come back to just the
same the the same thing we said earlier
though right which is okay so if the
situation remains as it is I mean look
and the Israelis are pretty hard-eyed
and cleare eyed about this stuff there's
a reason Israeli leaders have called
their periodic assaults on Gaza mowing
the lawn they don't really expect it to
accomplish anything you just have to go
in there occasionally and mow the lawn
they attack us you got to go hit them
back just to maintain the legitimacy of
the Israeli State and to establish at
least some level of deterrence among the
people who aren't already completely
captured by Haman
ideology but but but not with an idea
that it really accomplishes anything
long ter excuse me long
term
so it's really hard to figure out a way
that this
goes let me can I run something by you
yeah um because I don't know exactly how
I feel about this but but maybe as I as
I lay it out my feelings about it will
will firm up or or or maybe not um
people have looked at these videos that
have come out of people in Gaza people
on the street uh celebrating around the
corpse of an Israeli woman there was one
being paraded around um there's videos
like uh of after Israeli attacks just in
the past of of uh Palestinians
celebrating on the
street um and people point to that as a
sort of justification for a sense of
collective responsibility on these
people they voted in Hamas they cheer on
these attacks they might not have
carried them out but there's no reason
that we should be real squeamish about
about any attacks that happened to kill
those people because look at them
they're celebrating these
attacks the other the other side's
argument they would look and say okay
back in 1948 as the war was going on
there was a group called The Stern gang
Lei they called it in uh in Hebrew this
was a straightup terrorist organization
that sent mail bombs to British
officials in London may have sent mail
bombs to Harry Truman there's uh there's
a some evidence that that took place
although I I've only seen two places
there was a the guy who ran the mail
room at the White House for six
presidents wrote A Memoir about what
that was like and he was there during
Truman and he said that they had re Reed
mail bombs addressed to Truman from this
this Zionist group and then Harry
Truman's daughter wrote in her Memoir
that that had happened but she might
have been citing the other guy so I
don't know but still uh hardcore group
of people they planted bombs in
marketplaces that massacred hundreds of
Palestinians in 1948 a group of them
went into a village called Dar yine and
massacred everybody there it was a mili
Massacre kind of thing all the men were
gone uh all the military AG men were
gone because they were involved in the
fighting somewhere and they just came
and massacred all the women and children
and this is something that Israeli
historians have written about and uh
it's not really controversial anymore
about what happened it was a Meli style
Massacre that was carried out by this
group the stern ganger
Ley well Ley is still a recognized medal
in the Israeli Defense Forces so as iRun
which is another major terrorist
organization Zionist terrorist
organization that existed back then the
leader of that group when the daraen
massacre was carried out in 1948 was
yitzak Shamir who was later elected
prime minister of Israel the leader of
iRun the other terrorist organization
that killed huge numbers of civilians
killed a lot of British uh personnel as
well um including uh carrying out the
King David Hotel bombing which is where
the British used as their as their
headquarters um the leader of that group
was manakan Bean he was later elected
Israeli Prime Minister you take a guy
like Ariel Chiron
[Music]
who all all hyperbole aside I mean Ariel
Chiron is like a real deal 20th century
war criminal and there's a lot of
Israeli High officials including
military people who were in the
government with him who who think that
you go back to like 19 uh what was it
1981 the uh Israeli defense minister Bal
was being accused by some of his own
high officials of of uh in signing off
on on killings of civilians and so he
got run out of office and manin bean was
was prime minister at the time and he
was kind of old and scile a lot of
people say he was kind of like it was a
Biden situation where he's just sort of
checked out and that gave the people in
his government a lot of room to kind of
operate on their own and so he replaces
the defense minister with Ariel
Chiron and right away Ariel Chiron
wanted to go to war with Lebanon that's
what he wanted to happen because that's
where all of the after 1970 that's where
most of the Palestinian leadership was
they had been in Jordan but uh the after
Black September in 1970 the jordanians
ran him out they all went to Lebanon and
so Ariel Chiron wants to go to war with
Lebanon and he essentially works with
IDF Northern command and just complet
goes rad he's he's literally uh working
with IDF Northern command and Special
Operations groups up there and Bergman
writes about this in that in that book
you gave me rise and kill first where uh
they are I mean they killed hundreds of
civilians with uh with car bombs donkey
bombs other uh IEDs that they placed
around that were built in Israeli
Special Operations uh headquarters or
not the central headquarters in Tel Aviv
but up there in Northern command they
were building these bombs getting uh
locals to you know Pang them to go plant
them in areas with the specific goal and
again there's there's enough High
Israeli officials and military officials
from that time who are critical of what
Chiron was doing that we've kind of got
the full story on it now that his goal
was to ignite a civil war between the
Lebanese Christians the Shiites and the
Palestinians and so he would bomb the
Shiites and the Christians and try to
make it look like it was the
Palestinians he would bomb Palestinians
try to make it look like it was the
Shiites or the Christians to get them
going and I mean you know one car bomb
killed 83 civilians uh wounded another
300 a lot of the people who were killed
were women who worked in a in a clothing
Factory that all burned to death um and
there were hundreds and hundreds minimum
hundreds of people who were killed in
these straightforward terrorist attacks
right um he gets his way though they do
invade Lebanon on after some things kick
off it was actually as this is this
funny story actually Bergman writes how
uh as all these terrorist attacks were
going on Arafat and his people had
actually figured out what was happening
and they were putting out word on the
street to the to the groups they
controlled don't take the bait like they
want to invade us this is these are
there to provoke us don't take the bait
and that worked for a while but then
this kind of Lone Palestinian gunman up
in London killed the Israeli Ambassador
as he was coming out out of a an event
there in London and then that became uh
the the the reason that that allow you
know the the what a what is it Bella
kasus Bella yeah um for Israel and so
they went in and they invade Lebanon and
the entire time as they as the Lebanese
war is progressing Chiron is just
straight up lying to beg in the Prime
Minister and the rest of the government
he's like okay yeah all I'm doing
establishing a security perimeter right
here and like this this little part of
Southern Lebanon we just got to push
these people out cuz they're launching
you know Rockets or mortars at our
troops we're going to do that and he
would push out past that and you say
well now we have to it was just a you
know Mission creep but it was done very
consciously and so that they went all
the way up to
Beirut when they were in control of
Beirut uh there's the famous massacres
that took place at Sabra and chatila
which are two Refuge Palestinian refugee
camps where the Israeli Defense Forces
were in control of the area
and one of the Christian militias in
Lebanon that they were Allied to went in
there under the under the watch and and
we know now uh with the knowledge of a
lot of the people U you know they didn't
know exactly what was going to happen
but they knew there was going to be a
massacre and they let them go in and
they killed a thousand maybe
1500 uh Palestinian civilians women and
children massacred them cut them up
mutilated them was a horrible War crime
uh and uh so that happens they call they
call Ariel Chiron The Butcher of Beirut
every Palestinian calls him that all of
these stories that most Americans don't
know that most Israeli kids don't learn
about
um every single Palestinian knows all of
these stories and all the rest right and
so they would look at and be like this
guy this The Butcher of Beirut you
elected him prime minister and
so yeah there's videos of Palestinians
cheering after an Israeli attack you
elected this terrorist as your prime
minister and so how is that not the same
thing is that a similar thing like do do
one or neither or
both of those perspectives have any
validity well therein lies the problem
right therein lies the problem that you
that the way people are educated to what
they learn what gets
propagated it it makes people believe
and think a certain way and if you've
got two groups of people that have been
raised and educated to think a certain
way they're they're not going to come to
agreement on
much and this is what's so terrible
about the situation
is um you know even the last one we
posted I I I said something like no
answers you know no answers because
there's a lot of people that are
pontificating about what the right thing
to do is and and really what
unfortunately you know I always like to
think of okay how do we what do we do
what's the minimum amount of military
activity that we can move forward with
and find a solution like how can we do
this with with compromise how can we do
this with forgiveness how can we do this
with humanitarian attitudes
how can
we move forward in the most peaceful Pro
possible
way and again the last podcast we did
about this I started off with you know
Blood Meridian and this is where I end
up because at this
juncture again with with the
attitudes the way they are with the
beliefs the way they are with the
history the way it
is it is going I don't I don't I don't
think I can conceive
of a solution that is even
remotely uh
peaceful or even remotely you know that
even has any real real sort of Iota of
compromise in it it just really seems
like that that's where we're at and I
would say that
again I I give at least I I believe that
the
Israelis at least at this juncture
in in
history would like
to create peace and prosperity but I
don't it doesn't seem like they are
going to
be allowed to do
that
and the nihilistic nature of the of the
nihilistic nature of
Hamas you know why you you can just come
down with me and I'm going to take
whatever I can and I'm going to burn you
know the house that my grandma lived in
over in that Village I know I can't live
there but I'm going to burn it down
that's good enough and that's good
enough and that is
the you know I like to talk about
deescalation I like to talk about
forgiveness I like to talk about let's
let's put history in perspective but
let's not live in history let's
understand let's use history as a way to
understand each other not as a way to
form more animosity and you can see at
this
juncture it just doesn't seem like this
is what's going to happen
um
for yeah
yeah it's a tough situation right like
you think of a like imagine a person is
in a third floor window of a burning
building and they got to jump out of the
window or they're going to die and so
they jump out and they land on they land
on somebody and now they're on top of
him and this person who just got landed
on is not happy about it and he's saying
you know get off me and then the guy on
bottom pulls a knife he's like get off
me I'm gonna kill you well now the guy
on top says well I can't get off this
guy you know that would be would be
suicide I can't get off him I have to
stay on him and that goes on for a long
time that's really kind of the situation
that you could it's it's an analogy I
think that works for for what happened
in Israel and Palestine the Jews had to
find a place to live you know the the
lesson of the 40s of the Jews and the
40s and the Palestinians since then for
that matter is that every people needs a
state everybody every people needs a
state that is dedicated to their
well-being or else you are going to be
vulnerable to abuse uh by by peoples who
do have States and can engage in high
politics like that so um you know they
they needed a place to live and they
went to is they went to Palestine they
colonized that place and that you know
the the Palestinians themselves would
put it this way about how you know they
back in the 40s and 50s they're like we
didn't do the Holocaust we didn't have
anything to do with that like you're
punishing us like all you European
countries in the UN General Assembly
that just voted to Partition in our
country and give you know half of it to
to the
zionists give them part of Germany like
who are you kidding like we we have
nothing to do with this this whole thing
that's going on and yet it's all falling
on us and that's all true I mean I think
that's all true the Palestinians the
Jews were in an impossible situation in
Europe they needed somewhere to go what
was done to the Palestinians in the
process of that
was um it was it was a one-sided
atrocity I mean these people lost their
homes they lost their towns and Villages
that they had lived in for a long time
and herded into refugee camps and that's
terrible um but at a certain point when
that guy on bottom is has pulled a knife
and he's saying if soon as you let me up
soon as I have an opportunity I'm going
to cut your throat you know especially
if your if your kids are right there
next to you and everything you can't let
that guy up and I don't know how you do
that we all had that like experience on
a small scale with our little brother
brothers or little cousins or something
right like you're holding them down
messing with them and they're like let
they're just losing their mind like I'll
let you up if you stop fighting let you
up you stop I'm not gonna stop fighting
get off me it's like I'm not gonna let
you up and you just have to wear them
down and it's a similar situation in a
lot of ways I'm I shouldn't be laughing
I mean but it's uh it's an impossible
situation for for both sides any
Palestinian that tries to compromise
along lines that would be acceptable to
the Israelis especially in this
political environment is going to get
killed by Hamas or somebody else and
he's literally going to be killed
um and anything that would be uh that
that that that would be acceptable to
Palestinians under those conditions is
just it
has it's not even that there's no
political will for it in Israel it's
that they it would fatally compromise
Israel as a Jewish state it which just
wouldn't be able to remain what it is
it's just a you know know the the long
term if we look 500 years down the line
one of two things is going to happen is
either the Arabs are going to
demographically swamp the Israelis they
have a lot more babies technology is
going to continue to uh develop so that
you know we can make all these deals so
that Iran doesn't have a nuclear weapon
or that some terrorist group can't get
nuclear weapons or something for a while
but in 500 years can we do that like the
entire uh you know for the entire time
during that maybe not so that's one
direction that this goes
horrifying the other direction is that
the Palestinian
people as a collective identity group
you know as a people who is a
self-conscious group Palestinians you
know we are Palestinian Arabs that that
essentially goes away and those people
go become Egyptians they become uh
jordanians and syrians and maybe they
still have a sort of ethnic identity in
those places is so that like there's
Mexican Americans there's Palestinian
Egyptians and stuff but that that that
whole dream of having an independent
Palestine goes away and if you're a
Palestinian who you know whose grandma
was driven out of that home in ashalon
uh that's a that's a really ugly future
too
so
uh you know I always try and advise
people to take the high ground and not
only on the battlefield but more
important in life and in these political
situations and I think that I think that
that will be beneficial I over the near
term for people to try and take The High
Ground the moral High Ground about
what's happening again that's why I talk
about humanitarian efforts that's why I
talk about trying to find some level of
compromise try you you if you're not
doing those things you're going to be
perpetually putting yourself in a worse
and worse you're giving yourself less
and less Leverage to maneuver and that's
not going to work out well um I know you
you reached out on Twitter X and you
know hit up some if anybody had any
questions I know we're probably out of
time right now but uh any any any couple
of them that you want to hit real quick
yeah and we don't have to do them all
now I'm sure like uh you know this
conflict's gonna evolve very quickly and
and we'll talk about it again um one of
the one of the questions that I thought
was relevant to both of us and and our
sort of narrow range of expertise being
Navy guys is uh we've seen in recent
weeks or recent days rather that the US
is ordering second I think maybe a third
but certainly certainly uh at least two
carrier strike groups to the
region um what is the purpose of that
somebody asks what's the what's the
thinking of the people who who are
ordering that move um what purpose could
it serve and what are the risks of
having that thing over there at a time
like
this well clearly just out of the gate I
mean it's a show of support and show of
strength for Israel that's you know
that's out of the
gate it's also sort of like showing up
you know at the uh at the laser
tag the laser tag what do they call them
gym what do they call laser tag place
the laser tag place and you've got like
a Mark 48 machine gun yeah like are you
really going to be able to utilize this
in a way that makes sense you know like
you you're going to play go play laser
tag and you start mowing people down
with the Mark 48 machine gun that's so
sure guess what hopefully the people
that are playing laser tag are like okay
dude we get it like we'll settle down we
don't really want you in the game so
there's some of that going on um but
again when you've got sides that don't
really feel like settling down it's
going to be a problem yeah the I mean
and it and it it does raise the risk of
something happening that could
dramatically escalate the conflict right
and get us involved in a way that maybe
maybe we don't want to be uh back in
2006 during the Israeli War with
Hezbollah uh Hezbollah launched a an
anti- ship missile and hit an Israeli
frigate they've demonstrated that
capability I assume they've probably got
more and better weapons now than they
did then uh I know the houthis launched
a couple missiles at uh at us ships
passing by Yemen there um
I I would despair to think about what
would happen if we had one of our
carriers over there and it got shot by a
missile by anybody by Iran or Hezbollah
or anything like that it's uh I would
strongly advise if you're listening to
this podcast and you have any influence
don't shoot anything at American
aircraft carriers and it'll be really
problematic for you and the rest of the
world and like that that's I'm not
kidding that's just not that's just not
going to work out well for one it's not
going to accomplish any anything just so
you know carriers are damn near
impossible to sync modern carriers your
little uh you know offbrand Charlie 802
anti- ship missiles not going to do it
you're just going to be a pain in the
ass and we are going to destroy you and
everybody you know so don't do that all
right what's another question
um what would you yeah we've kind of
addressed this a little bit uh but let's
just sort of lay it out there you're you
are you're not even the Israeli Prime
Minister you are the king of Israel or
maybe we're not going to use that term
you're the uh you're the Emperor of
you're the Emperor of Israel uh you're
in just you've got total god mode Powers
over Israeli policy uh something like
this
happens in the historical context that
we're currently and everything as it is
now uh what do you what do you do well I
think the immediate reaction that Israel
executed on which was like securing the
the fences getting like that immediate
mil military action that they took was
was really good it was a good solid
military action that they took quickly
um at this juncture you know I think
it's going to be and I think I
would like you said I already kind of
said what I'd be doing I would be I
would probably stop bombing Gaza right
now you've got there's people in tunnels
the enem is you're not killing you're
not killing bad guys at this juncture
with with uh air strikes so what you're
doing is just
destroying you're destroying the city
and you're giving Hamas opportunities to
win the information operations if I was
Emperor of Israel right now we would be
annihilating on the information
operations we would be doing
humanitarian missions we would be
showing and doing things that would ex
show the world what our attitude was and
that we
weren't the uh aggressors here and that
we were going to try and do our best and
I would also be showing that to the the
Palestinians as well that they need to
see like oh there's opportunity out here
you know and I know that they have you
know they had work programs where the
Palestinians could go out and work in
Israel I I would have expanded that I
mean right now it's really difficult but
okay well if you go through these metal
detectors and you show up here and we
know who you are yep you can go to work
out here every day and as a matter of
fact you can live out here you can we
can set you up so I would start really
trying to take care of the Palestinian
people trying to show them goodwi trying
to take care of the civilians in the in
the highest possible way that I could
and then I would go
and execute missions where we eliminate
Hamas and that's what I would do when
you before before we started recording
you showed me a video of uh the
aftermath of some strikes on Hamas it
was just you know A Wasteland and the
first thing I thought whenever I see
something like that uh you know as you
as somebody who who has has combat
experience as a soldier when you see a
landscape like that knowing that there's
tunnels uh throughout the area and
everything what are you thinking when
you look at that it's a nightmare it's a
nightmare and and that's why like even
again going to the emperor position I
would not be super excited to roll in
there and start hunting for Hamas with
my troops I'm going to take a lot of
casualties I'm going to take a ton of
you want to start talking about clearing
what do they say 300 miles of tunnels is
what's what's down there 300 miles
tunnels 300 miles of tunnels this to me
turns into Siege Warfare and I start
doing Siege Warfare with this
overarching idea of benevolence to take
care of the civilian
populace and show them that we will help
we are here we
we don't we want to we want to figure
out uh a peaceful solution to this we're
going to help you out and we're going to
starve and and Crush Hamas and oh you
don't want to get starved and crushed
cool come to this location at this time
you know we could we'll give you food
and water we'll help you to the best of
our ability we'll give you medical
support oh we go we're going to go in
we're going to secure because I I'm not
going to secure all of Gaza but we can
secure this area now we can have
checkpoints going into another where we
can start normalizing life there start
showing people uh the better opportunity
that loot that is out there besides the
nihilistic Hamas Way
Forward that's what I would do I would
really and and look I know that this
sucks and you want to know why I know
this sucks cuz when my guys got
killed we had to still continue to work
with the civilian populace we had to go
and try and help them build projects out
in the city we had to put our guys at
risk to conduct civil Affairs
operations and I know it
sucks but that is how you actually get
the other side to see your perspective a
little bit as
well I mean to
to the first the first thing that has to
happen if you're going to win those
hearts in Minds though right is you have
to you have to destroy Hamas just like
when you were in ramadi you could you
could uh drill all the wells and do all
the things you wanted none of that
matters if you don't kill the jihadists
in that city right the thing is you said
first you have to do this it's going to
be a simultaneous operation because if
you focus only on killing Hamas right
now and you don't do anything
humanitarian to support prior to you're
going to kill everybody or you're going
to at least starve everybody or there's
going to be real problems so you it has
to be a uh uh
simultaneous lines of operations that
you're executing at the same time and
look from a political perspective that's
going to
be it's going to be challenging but you
have to
explain to the team just like I had to
explain to Young freaking seals that
worked for me hey this is what we're
doing this is why we're doing it this is
why this is beneficial this is why this
is going to help us strategically in the
long run
that's what the government of Israel is
gonna have to it would probably take
somebody like Netanyahu to do that right
because nobody's goingon to look at
Netanyahu and be like oh he's soft on
the Palestinians he's in a good position
to be able just like I was in a good
position to do that you know I was an
aggressive leader and you know very
aggressive doing combat operations so
when I explained hey we're also going to
do these operations the guys weren like
oh no he's weak no it's like we're
actually conducting what is the all the
lines of operation
in counterinsurgency Warfare and this is
what our job is so when guys understand
that and that's what the the civilian
populace of Israel and again are there
going to be some hardcore that are going
to be like this is I don't want
to risk my life I don't want to put one
penny towards humanitarian efforts they
voted for Hamas they supported they
cheered in the streets they all nope
that's you cannot we as in leadership
positions you have to be balanced and
you have to help pull people into a more
balanced position that's what your goal
is in a leadership position the mob is
going to be moving and when the mob
starts moving in the wrong direction
you're the one that has to pull it back
Center when and if you get caught up in
the mob or you support the mob they're
just going to fly off the handle so
you're the one and and look the mob
might be too aggressive they might be
not aggressive enough you know if in a
different world it may be like well you
know we can understand why this happened
and we just kind of have to accept the
fact that if Hamas feels this aggravated
they should have the right to come and
kill like that would be obviously too
far it's like the London mayor said
these kinds of after the Ariana Grande
concert he said well terrorist attacks
like this are just part and parcel of
living in a modern major city yeah so
that's again that's what you're not
going to do uh but it takes a real it's
going to take some real leadership there
if they're going to move in Direction
and they should be looking at it from a
strategic perspective and saying listen
we've got to do a better job of
information operations we are looking
like the bad guy we are looking like the
oppressor we are looking like and and
that's what they're looking like and you
need to actually do things so you don't
look like that and you can't just do
propaganda you actually have to do
things and make that effort and go out
there and it and it is risky this is
what's scary is it's risky there's no
promise that just because you're
carrying water into Gaza that you're not
going to get blown up and killed you can
get blown up and killed carrying water
into Gaza no doubt about it you know how
many you know how many soldiers in Iraq
got blown up on Logistics convoys on
what we called medcaps going out like
those things are going to happen it's a
risk but those are the risks that you
have to take in order to move in a
Direction that's going to put some kind
of positivity on this and you know I
thought kind of where you were going
with at some point the Palestinians You'
got to it's exactly what happened in
Iraq where the local populace starts
saying okay I get it the freaking
insurgents are are are bad they're bad
and they just want everyone to die and
the Americans I heard a lot of bad
things about them but they gave us water
they are helping us with our you know P
Paving this road out here they gave some
medical treatment to my kid uh they they
don't seem that bad as I thought and the
next thing you know they realize that
they actually the Americans just want us
to have a nice little city and be able
to carry on and a nice little country
and be able to carry
on that takes a couple Generations as I
mentioned like because those beliefs Run
Deep and you've been told a bunch of
different things throughout your life I
mean think about the
re-education that going to have to
happen on both sides right to say yeah
you know what there's a reason that
there's grievances oh yeah you know what
there's a reason that there's grievances
both sides need to be saying that yeah
and it goes to the the information Ops
part of it that you're talking about too
because I'm telling you the information
operations here is this is the most
strategic part of this whole campaign on
both sides right now Hamas is winning
Hamas has a more uh worldwide the the
audience globally is more attuned
to want to listen to Hamas does that
have to something to do with the fact
that we've got this sort of culture of
oppressor versus oppressed and right you
know Hamas is putting themselves out
there as the oppressed and the global
world right now thinks that oppressed
people are the ones that need support of
course that's how we all got raised
that's what the like the freaking
Special Forces the Green Berets their
motto is Liberate the oppressed right
right that's what their motto is that's
what they live for that's and so that's
how we're raised and we believe that the
people that are
oppressed are good that's our sort of
our thought is like well they're good
the oppressed people are good the the
oppressors are bad because why would
oppressors oppress they do that because
they're bad what we don't realize is
that sometimes the
oppressed are Nazis sometimes the
oppressed are
extremists that actually should be
oppressed now what happens in this
situation you know again I liked out of
the gate that there was some some sort
of
uh differentiation between Hamas and
Palestine Hamas did a great job of
making Hamas Palestinian they they are
the they are the Palestinian cause as
opposing to be a freaking terrorist
cause cuz you've got to think a normal
Palestinian person that's been living in
Gaza is like bro you know what I want a
freaking job and water that's what I
want I want my family I want my kids to
go to school
and to to set them up Hamas has done a
great job of setting themselves up as
the Palestinians and one of the reasons
that they tend to win the information
Ops uh battle is is that in a way they
have an easier job right in the sense
that homos if like if World opinion
turns against
tamas that's actually fine that's
they're not really in any worse of a
situation than they were before that as
long as the intensity of emotions and
hatred and everything goes up to prevent
any fatal compromises they're going to
subvert their maximal skain then that's
good as long as the level of intense
emotions goes up and that is easier to
do uh yeah you know what you said too
about you know the the ones who may be
oppressed you can step back and look at
this from a historical perspective and
say no doubt these people are
oppressed that does not as much as we
always sort of uh have have interpreted
that way does does not make them the
good guys you know like that's one thing
n had right yes power can corrupt but
weakness and continual defeat can
corrupt the soul as surely as anything
and that is something that that I mean
there's no doubt that it's happened in
Gaza to a large degree I it's not as bad
in the West Bank but you know that I
think I might have mentioned this in the
last episode but they you know there
have been independent journalists and
stuff who've gone and taken polls of
Palestinian schools and classrooms
little 12-y old 10y olds and ask them
what do you want to do when you grow up
and something like 65 or 70% say I want
to be a martyr and it's like you know
well everybody wants to climb the status
ladder in their particular society and
in the context of that Society things
have warped so much that that is what
people what kids aspire to and it's like
you said that's a that's a
generational solution uh if if it's if
there's any solution if there if there
is a solution we got one more question
are we good I think we're good we're
pushing up on 90 minutes we'll get to
some of these others again all right
well wish we had some more good news for
you unfortunately we don't this is the
way things are going check out our other
podcasts uh I have Joo podcast Warrior
kid podcast and Joo underground go to
Joo underground.com Daryl has his
podcast called martyr made of course to
get the background you know he went went
through 15 minutes of History he's got
how many hours is the first six episodes
of martyr made I think maybe 27 or so if
you want to hear the a little more
background you can get 27 hours of it uh
his podcast is called martyr made he
also has a
substack which is Martyr made. substack
do.com and I've got some stuff that you
can get at Joost store.com joof fuel.com
origin
usa.com and that's what we're doing also
have a leadership consulting company
where we teach people about leadership
so you don't get caught in terrible
situations that's it for now thanks for
listening as things really
unfortunately start to unravel this is
Daryl and Joo out